[Musique]
hier soir m6 diffusait la seconde partie
de la demi finale de la france a un
incroyable talent une soirée placée sous
le signe de la bonne grosse ya là deux
mois je me fait rigoler
je m'assieds on se le dise cette saison
devant nos écrans c'était plutôt les
français ont des incroyables rats sera
chaque candidat avait des histoires
toujours plus tristes à nous raconter
hier soir c'est la prestation de bieber
qui a ému le jury
mon père nous inquiéter en 1995 et
j'avais 4 ans seulement le breakdancer
handicapés des deux jambes a même obtenu
le golden buzzer de la partie s'anime
gare l'invité du soir
[Applaudissements]
les prestations certes impressionnant
mais souvent considérée comme larmoyante
comme avec aurélie et son pigeon mort il
ya deux semaines c'était censé vous
faire un duo d'équilibré avec un pigeon
un oiseau depuis 16 ans et il m'a quitté
ya dix jours ou encore bernard 92 ans en
fauteuil roulant qui a réalisé un slam
très émouvant qu'il fasse jour qu'il
fasse nuit
les soeurs ne compte plus la vie est
ralentie une soirée de divertissement
qui nous a donné envie d'aller se
coucher alors la france a un incroyable
talent faut-il faire pleurer pour gagner
aller chercher on est avec eric antoine
dont je suis un grand fan il le sait et
eric merci d'être là mon chéri nexus
uffheim de toi mais vraiment tu sais moi
aussi moi qui tu as parlé de rapidité tu
vas vite
en même temps tu es [ __ ] tu détestes
tout le monde mais tu les aimes commerce
série je veux parler le truc
d'abord avant toute chose il ya les
goûts master les arrive sur m6
ce sera le mercredi 23 décembre oui mais
je vous le dis et je le dis à eric est
là parce qu'eric manière à chaque fois
tu me dis ça parce que tu me quittes
donc tu me dis que ça va cartonner
légaux au masters le concours de lego
noah je vous le dis draper il avait fait
un truc sur les dominos et bien sûr yeux
des salles et domino des salles et à
véritable carton je pense que les gosses
tu te rends pas compte du carton que ça
va être
j'ai appelé la chaîne pour le dire je
veux animer cette émission avec l aps à
tel point noir pour te dire à quel point
j'aime dans médéric sarko la question
pensent de lego vasseur je pense que ça
va être une des plus belles audiences de
m6 seule année moi aussi je te le dire
ainsi c'est pernikoff qui vit et moi et
moi je sors larissa ma voix mes amis
mais je vais le rebond d'hier sur ce
qu'a dit cyril le domino day je sais pas
si vous vous souvenez à l'époque
personne n'y croyait bien sûr c'est
qu'en fait le carton que ça a été
certainement amené moi-même avait même
dit à tf1 si l'émission fait pas cinq
millions je vous rembourserai d'acheter
le produit leur avait ri ça c'est vrai
ça lui en a coûté cette vision protéger
la ccisam et non parce que mèneraient
pas ce que tu fais de demain on à vis de
passe partout il sera très bien
on me l'avait proposé domino des mois
j'avais dit non mais vous plaisantez
les gens vont rester deux autres jurés
des dominos de tomber je refuse et moi
j'ai un ami qui l'avait fait famille et
d'un livre lien avec les sept n'avaient
pas pris 17 millions de dollars de
capitaux en gare à vache quand même aimé
moi je te dis donc t'es numéro 1 sur tf1
mais sur ces huit numéros combien le
numéro 2 ouais pour moi il est numéroté
numéro un voici je te le dis voilà et
les chéris ce sera le 23 décembre à 21h
les gommages sanders et je te dis allez
3,4 millions dans quatre plus tard de
323 des serments plus il ya quatre
millions et demi quatre millions et demi
nicolas pernikoff on verra ça eric tu
vas faire une sorte de tournée digital
aussi exceptionnel le concept c'est
génial du samedi 12 au 27 décembre à 16
heures ou 20 heures
tut invite chez les gens avec 19
représentations exceptionnelles en ligne
ça c'est très fort
alors que ce sera accessible sur où
exactement j'adore toutes les infos sur
mon site internet
c'est un choix que j'ai écrit et pour le
pour le digital pour nous rapprocher par
exemple les grands soirs chez vous à
être avec les petits enfants
moi je vais faire un tour de magie pour
que les les petits enfants devine la
carte à laquelle les grands parents
pensent ou alors on va tous pensé on va
avoir des transmissions télépathique les
on va penser la même chose au même
moment j'adore à la pontaise où tu sais
aussi tous les garçons pensent la même
chose ici tu vois que tu vas dans les
cerveaux de tous les mecs c'est delphine
wespiser rouge on voit que c'est vrai
qu'on ne voit qu'elle est on est content
de l'avoir mais il s'appelle aussi
établiront rouge et je sais qu'elle est
dans ma tête dans mon dossier les
incroyables talents et genoni
cette saison était bien sûr marquée par
quelques problèmes incroyable talent
liés aux coronavirus les enregistrements
ont été parfois repoussée visiblement
demi-finalistes jugés positifs aux
communes n'a pas pu être présent
absolument défendre
nous avons enregistré convaincre watan
on devait enregistrer fin août j'ai eu
le vide on a repoussé des notes trois
semaines ensuite on a enregistré toutes
les émissions dont la finale qui
normalement être joint en direct à corps
et donc les téléspectateurs vont quand
même voter pour l'émission parce que
nous on ne sait pas qui va gagner on
aura un résultat en fonction des votes
des téléspectateurs qu'on annoncera sur
un mode arcade et ouais donc on s'est
adapté cieux alors c'est vrai que hier
regarder il n'a pas pu être là un des
candidats mais on veut pas voir
l'extrait bus qui nous l'a dit
les internautes ont jugé des missions
trop larmoyant qu'on arrête
bon alors que tu en penses écoute j'ai
passé des manières mais en fait non moi
je regarde pas une fois que j'ai fait
l'émission je regarde pas l'émission
j'ai j'ai une vie en dehors
et donc quand je fais des grandes
productions ainsi tu fais avec les
choses abidjan la maison venez on va me
regarder qui vient vous regarder ce soir
je sais pas mais en effet il ya des
ennemis et des candidats qui nous
émeuvent et évidemment j'ai entendu ici
ça je me souviens très bien des cnisag
golden buzz et à quel point il était ému
sincèrement donc qu'est ce que tu veux
faire on vit un truc
sincèrement on est ému par quelqu'un
alors schiano tracé puis et le jeu était
bouleversé et après c'est vrai qu'il
joue pas un
la comédie est en tout cas très nombreux
d'entre vous
c'est tellement intelligent alex un
talent extraordinaire
les images sont somptueux car ces
fabuleuses quand je regarde ce que tu
viens nous montrer je me dis dans quel
monde on vit on se déshumanise derrière
nos masques mais je crois que l'amour et
la solidarité sont les clés de tout ça
aujourd'hui on a tous les yeux braqués
sur nos téléphones et on partage pas
toujours ce qu'il ya autour de nous en
fait parfois on n'a pas de parents mais
ça nous rend plus fort que quand on en
main parce que finalement on choisit nos
propres parents peut-être que tu t'es
demander ce que tu devenais faire sur
terre mais pour moi tu es plus une
petite étoile tu bois main que tu es toi
j'ai une inspiration
voilà ce que tu es une inspiration ah
oui alors magnifique et quel bonheur de
voir hélène ségara est vraiment vraiment
eric antoine et issa doumbia
on va pas se mentir les grands moments
d'émotion comme ça c'est ce que
cherchent les chaînes en ce moment ça
marche beaucoup mieux on parlait de thé
au lavabo la semaine dernière ma que
j'adore - dans l'air du temps les
buzzcocks à rome mais ça cartonne varie
selon les modes cherche plus des grands
moments d'émotion comme ça parce que ça
marche bien c'est très fort pour les
téléspectateurs
c'est une scéne alchimie en fait c'est
une bonne recette de gâteau il faut un
peu de sel
ça fait ressortir le sucre et la ddt
niel l'émotion d'inactivité
[Applaudissements]
oui satie personnellement je trouve ça
tellement dommage en fait de jouer sur
l'histoire alors certes il est vraiment
talentueux mais c'est ils ont foutu tout
paquet là-dessus juste pour que ça
marche ou ça vraiment dommage
en fait il peut tellement brillé de
lui-même sans toute cette histoire mais
non c'est vraiment parfaite séféris je
n'y a plus d'espacé pour les artistes à
la télévision aujourd'hui à ixelles sont
les espaces on peut s'exprimer où on
peut exprimer notre art en dehors de la
chanson de la carton c'est un des seuls
choses l'humour et la chanson on sait
une nouvelle star qui ne laisse pas sur
l'émission politique de france 2
évidemment donc non c'est l'émission qui
est essentielle et c'est que quelques
minutes us f1 numéro de deux minutes on
parle sur lui trois minutes
c'est vraiment très petit espace
justement en tout cas pour un peu moins
de talent j'ai dit hier je m'attendais
un peu plus je dis la vérité
oui j'ai dit à l'heure parce que tf1 est
à la ramasse mais ça reste quand même
une nouvelle saison 3 millions et demi
en moyenne là je crois que ça doit faire
entre 3 6 et 3 sets je pense que ça
passera les quatre millions quand eric
antoine soit non seulement membre du
jury ont plus que de retaper leur
démission
il n'a pas voté le golden buzzer parce
que l'histoire est émouvant il a voté et
on l'entend le doute alors parce que le
mcs abandonné mais tout le poids de son
corps sur deux bois dans soleil samedi
bien sûr c'est non mais on sent que
c'est ce qu'apporte le morceau regardez
d'ailleurs le golden boy george issa
doumbia
regardez mon père nous a quitté en 1995
et j'avais 4 ans seulement
et ma mère en 1998 j'avais 7 ans
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'espère que vous serez fiers de nos
casques johnny
le tableau il est fou le message savoir
tout ça sur toi et avoir une énergie
folle comme ça et un talent monstre
comme tuer mais qui je suis désolé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vraiment pas comme ça il est droit il a
bien sûr fait ce qu'on peut ce qu'on
peut reprocher c'est tout l'artifice de
réalisation avec la même passion
découvrir les images avec vous mais
c'est vrai que ça fait un peu mélo moi
je suis pas du tout d'accord et vous que
c'est il faut comprendre l'énergie du
mec qui fait est juste incroyable
il faut voir d'où il vient et bidouille
moi je suis fan de baseball depuis le
début je pense que justement de
comprendre tout ce qu'il a traversé pour
en arriver là et puis d'accord vous
savez bien et que tpm peu ouvert à tous
je veux dire il n'y a pas de place pour
le handicap en transférant avec vous et
sont claires et c'est juste moi je suis
fière d'avoir fait ça pour ça
à un moment on s'est engueulé avec
marianne on a dit marine 066 message un
peu plus des numéros à message oui mais
sauf que aujourd'hui encore une
homophobie hallucinant bien sûr il ya
une violence hallucinante verra un
racisme hallucinant donc à un moment on
est bien obligé de le dire et je trouve
que c'est bien que ce soit fait dans
cette émission si je suis d'accord -
eric 2 euros sur m6 très c'est vrai
ouais vraiment m engager quand tu
regardes pas d'avoir ne pas avoir été
sur france télévisions faucher qui te
voulait absolument rencontre en plus ils
voulaient que tu animes boyard landreau
ne manquez pas les abats boyard londres
choix tu serais resté là d'amidon
l'adorent on y devine il a plein
d'autres trucs donc voilà donc olivier
voilà c'est vrai qu'il y avait mes
frères c'est génial sarah jane lb boyer
volte-face par l'endroit des nationaux
noir